whichever one i was writing at the
moment that was my favorite because i
was really
into it but i love them all
i have to mention i'm probably my
biggest fan
i love everything i've done
when you give characters superhuman
powers
super powers still finding a way to make
them believable and
empathetic and that's the trick
and if there is a secret to how to do it
and i don't know if there is or not
but if i did know i wouldn't tell
because we don't need the competition
just being able to see spider-man
web swing from building the building as
dramatically as he does
if they tried to film that 25
30 years ago it would look a little bit
corny
when we created the characters like
spider-man and the hulk
and so forth years ago they weren't even
computers
everything was colored by hand and inked
and penciled we never
in a million years suspected that one
day there would be
3d action movies based on these
characters
actually we just hoped the books would
sell and we keep our jobs and be able to
pay the rent that was as far ahead as we
would look
i formed a company called pow how stands
for
purveyors of wonder and we're doing
movies and television shows and things
on the internet we
we have a new channel called stan lee's
world of heroes we have something called
stan's rants
where i just talk about all the things
that bother me
like how does superman fly he has
no visible means of propulsion
right oh we have cocktails with stan
where i interview people whom i think
are interesting not the usual guests
that they have on interview shows
and as long as we don't drink too much
during the interview it works okay but
since we're serving cocktails
we never know how any interview is going
to end and then at powell
we have a movie about a new superhero
who's chinese
and it's called the annihilator we even
have
a a live action show an arena show
called yin and yang the power of tau
and that'll be presented first in macau
in the orient and it's the only show
where the audience becomes part
of the story itself i mean i didn't know
i was going to do an interview for wired
i wish i had time to study and think of
exciting things to say
i hope this is just preparation and you
let me do it in real life later on